did you ever wonder what would happen if
muzan won what would he do after that
and would there be anyone left to stop
him the answers to these questions are
actually really surprising and probably
not what you are expecting alright let's
first see in which ways muzon could have
won there is a total of four big
mistakes he made that prevented him from
winning and two of those mistakes
happened within a few minutes of each
other for example in season 1 of the
anime the very first chance moves on
gets to win is when he meets tanjaro for
the first time in Tokyo at that time
Tundra was just an amateur Demon Slayer
with minimal experience and skills he
was very weak and wouldn't have been
able to even scratch the demon king with
the powers he had in fact he even
struggled to defeat a swamp demon only
an episode early therefore muzon could
have easily ended tantra's life at that
time with just one simple attack and the
anime would have ended at episode 7.
however that's not what happened as soon
as muzon spotted tanza wrote hanafuda
earrings he thought he saw a ghost of
yurichi and didn't want to take the risk
of attacking him immediately and you
can't really blame the guy he didn't
really have a fun time the last time he
engaged a sun breathing user so I guess
it's understandable why he didn't do it
right well no you are missing one very
important detail muzon is a demon king
for a reason and is very much capable of
sensing a person's strength and power
considering this Luzon should have been
able to easily determine that Tantra
wasn't really a threat at that time and
dispose of him immediately so why didn't
he do anything well you'll have to ask
him that but we'll just say that he was
really shocked by the earrings and
couldn't really think straight in any
case it was only his first out of four
mistakes so let's cut him some slack for
now but what about his very next
decision only a few moments later you
see just a few minutes after his
encounter with tanjaro muzon ordered two
demons to go after and eliminate him one
would think that this was a brilliant
decision on his part but that's not
really the case there's nothing wrong
with sending his subordinates to take
care of tundra what's wrong is that he
sent susumaru and yahaba which are not
even a part of the 12 kizuki so let me
get this straight muzon ran away from
Tantra because he was scared of him and
his master plan was to send his two
weekend demons to dispose of him man
this guy's not really that smart now I
know what you guys are thinking the
demon wounds were probably too far away
at that time even if that was the case
and all the moons were really too far
away it still doesn't make any sense
because of the one small detail muzon
has the option to get them teleported to
wherever he desires with the help of
nakeem and her Infinity Castle just
imagine if he had done that and asked
Doma or kokushibu to take care of tundra
if he was still afraid that Tundra was
too strong he could even send all upper
moons together to make sure he is dead
just imagine all seven upper moons
marching towards tantro at the same time
the fight would be over in a second
before we continue any further I want to
thank RuneScape for sponsoring this
video RuneScape is an open world fantasy
MMORPG where you can explore vast and
ever-changing worlds chances are you
probably heard about RuneScape but did
you hear about their brand new event
called Fresh Start worlds Fresh Start
worlds is a four month members only
event where you can experience a
completely reset version of RuneScape
and play it like it's your first time if
you've never played RuneScape before
this is the best time to get started as
every player starts equally with a
completely new character and zero skills
the entire world is also completely
reset with new economy and Grand
exchange if you start playing now you'll
be able to progress at an incredible
Pace with XP boost and gameplay Buffs
that'll be available only for the first
eight weeks of the event during the
entire event you'll also be able to earn
rare tradable rewards and don't worry at
any time you'll be able to transfer your
tradable rewards to the main game along
with your character and progression
RuneScape fsw requires a new account
with membership activated in order to
play luckily if you already have Amazon
Prime you'll be able to claim seven days
of free membership and try it out for
everyone who doesn't have Amazon Prime
you can click my link in the description
to make a brand new RuneScape account
now and start playing okay muzon made
some really bad decisions so far but
surely he didn't make any worse mistakes
than these right wrong The Demon King
actually made two more insanely stupid
mistakes for example in season 3 when
the upper Moon ranked six demons gyutoro
and daki were fighting the Demon Slayers
they had countless chances to eliminate
all of them still they decided to be
cocky and toy with them instead now you
must be wondering how exactly is this
muzon's fault well if you think that
muzan was not aware of what was
happening in the Entertainment District
it probably means that you missed this
one small piece of information in the
manga you see in the chapter 182 it was
revealed that the Demon King can
actually see through the eyes of all the
demons he has created this means that he
should have been able to see that yutoro
and daki were fighting tantro and
looking at how the fight was going Luzon
could have easily sent some help through
the infinity castle and finally defeated
tanzaro but what did he do instead he
just watched the two demons get defeated
by the demon Slayers and decided to do
absolutely nothing about it muzan's
actions make it appear that he either
greatly underestimated the demon Slayers
again or he just simply didn't want to
kill Tundra at all which would make even
less sense moving forward the LA fast
and the worst mistake that the Demon
King made which ultimately resulted in
his death occurred during the infinity
Castle Arc at the end of chapter 136 in
the manga muzon decides to muster some
courage and finally deal with the demon
Slayers in person however it's exactly
here that he made a very crucial and
stupid mistake no doubt muzon is
incredibly powerful but entering the
enemy's stronghold all by himself that
doesn't really seem like the best idea
right and to what cause only to insult
kagaya how old and ugly he is come on
man you can do better than that are you
stupid because of this decision muzan
got injured by explosives and injected
with poison and therefore he couldn't
fight the hashira right away and instead
had to regenerate and wait until all the
demon moons were defeated now take a
moment to think about this what if muzon
had actually made a solid plan and
immediately transported all the hashira
into the infinity Castle this way he'd
be able to attack the demon Slayers
along with all the demon moons together
and that would have easily guaranteed
him the victory in no time you'd think
that after living for over a thousand
years muzan would be experienced enough
to avoid a mistake like this but I guess
experience doesn't come with age in
muzon's case alright before we get into
explaining what would happen to the
world if muzan actually managed to win
and defeat all the demon Slayers let's
first see if the Demon Slayer core could
have done anything to stop him well
remember the first two chances muzon got
to kill tanjaro back then the Demon
Slayer Corps had no idea about tanjaro's
connection with yorichi they were
unaware of how special he was and that
he possessed sun-breathing abilities
therefore it's only fair that we don't
blame the core for not protecting him
during those times however when they
finally found out about his abilities
and their importance why did they think
it was a good idea to sent him with
tenjin to fight upper Moon demons I mean
think about it aren't there like six
more ashiras who could have definitely
done a better job in handling the
situation compared to tanjaro and his
friends granted it's true that tantro
did get stronger from all these fights
it was still extremely risky and he
could have died really easily so my
question is why didn't they just keep
him safe and send him to train with
other hashira he would have become much
stronger this way and would be fully
prepared for his battles against upper
moons and muzon it turns out that the
Demon Slayer core isn't that bright
either now finally let's talk about the
most important topic muzon's win against
the core what would have happened if the
Demon King had actually won the final
battle effectively defeating all the
hashiras and the demon Slayers at this
point everyone who was strong enough to
oppose him would be dead although some
of the former members who didn't
participate in the fight like tenjin
would still be alive there is absolutely
nothing they would be able to do after
defeating the demon Slayers in the final
battle Busan would achieve his goal of
immortality by eating nezuko this would
mean that he would successfully conquer
the Sun and would make him an
undefeatable being so with his Newfound
powers and immortality what would the
great Demon King do next if you think
that he would kill all humans make an
army of demons and wreak havoc on the
world you'd be completely wrong there
are a few hints in the anime that tell
us exactly what he would do if we judge
muzon's character throughout the series
he doesn't strike you as the type of
villain who would take joy in
meaningless and senseless production no
he's much more elegant than that and
mass destruction is definitely not his
style let's take a look at episode 8
when he was in Tokyo and bumped into
some drunk people in the alley
considering his strength and the fact
that he's evil muzon could have ended
them right then and there but he was
very sophisticated about it being the
first one to apologize after they
prevented him from leaving he apologized
again and tried to leave without hurting
them seeing this it's pretty obvious
that muzon isn't your average villain
interested in spreading chaos and
destruction his motivation would most
likely be to rule the world and he would
prefer to keep humans alive he'd also
probably stick to concealing his
identity as a normal human as he's done
countless times in the anime
additionally since nothing would pose
threat to him anymore he'd have no need
for sharing his powers with other demons
therefore there's a huge possibility
that he would kill the remaining kizuki
and be the only demon to exist the
remaining members of the poor hiria
sukonji and tenjin would most likely try
to reform the organization recruiting
new members and training them however it
would all be in vain as muzon would be
quite lit literally Unstoppable his only
weakness was the Sun and with that out
of the way there is no way of defeating
him the man would easily defeat and
squash them if they ever tried to do
anything against him in the end with
everyone out of the way muzon would
fulfill his wish of immortality and rule
over the world as a king for thousands
of years and no one would be able to do
anything to stop him did you ever wonder
if all demon moons together can defeat
muzon well click on this video to find
out the answer may surprise you